publisher take-two is somewhat unique
and that many of its biggest non sports
franchises such as Grand Theft Auto red
dead redemption and Max Payne are not
released on an annual basis by
comparison Activision releases a new
call of duty every year while Ubisoft
puts out a new Assassin's Creed every
fall now take to CEO Strauss Zelnick has
shared some insight into the company's
approach speaking today at the mkm
partners investor day in New York City
so like said annual ization can lead to
the erosion in the value of a given
brand the market asks us why don't you
annualize your titles we think with the
non sports titles we are better served
to create anticipation and demand on the
one hand to rest the title and on the
other hand to have the highest quality
in the market which takes time you can't
do that annual although take two has no
plans to release its tentpole franchises
every year outside of sports games like
NBA 2k and WWE 2k selnick said the
company could still generate the kind of
revenue that annual ization would
provide through other means he went on
to say what we would like to do is to be
able to have enough hit intellectual
properties in any given year whether we
have title a or title b is not the issue
we'll have a handful of really great
franchises and new intellectual
properties that together really have the
economic impact of an annualized
business without the detriments of an
annualized business i think i'm on take
two side here annual ization in this
industry is inevitable but it's nice
having a publisher that takes a
different approach but at the same time
it's been almost six years since red
dead redemption I think it's time for a
sequel rockstar
you